I think one thing that could be done is
that we could do some sort of prison
reform where we start putting webcams in
prisons for inmates that are supervised
and allow them to communicate with
therapists and family so we really do
turn it into a sort of
um I don't know a place where people can
actually become better as opposed to
just retribution and Vengeance and we
want them we don't want people to suffer
in prison we want them to become better
humans but I can take it one step
further I I just I realized this the
other day very very simple solution if
you break the law you are uh we
forcefully give you the meta the the
neurolink implant and then plug you in
and delete from your brain criminality
dude no joke that is something that
could happen they I think it's like A
Clockwork Orange yeah they were talking
about neural networks early on when they
were talking about Elon was talking
about neural net that you could dampen
emotional receptors with it I think